Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P
here is a seventeen year old who called in
saying his mom doesn't want him vaccinated.
What should he do? Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Hey, David,
long time listener. I've been
listening for about three years now,
and I'm in quite a predicament right now. I'm 17
and my mom is the one that you vaccinated just
despite everyone else in my family be vaccinated.
And I was just wondering how you would go about
kind of. Getting through the disinformation
and really kind of breaking through is like
a family member is specific about just, you
know, trying to get behind public safety.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing. It depends on
whether your goal is to convince someone or to
get vaccinated as quickly as possible. I don't
know what it would take to convince your mom
to let you get the vaccine. Now, the truth
is that depending on what state you're in,
you don't need parental permission at
age 17 to go and get vaccinated. Now,
we did a story on the bonus show a few weeks
ago about how the new hot thing for teenagers
is helping each other get vaccinated when they
have anti VAX parents. I would never encourage
anyone to break the law, but what I would say is
find out what options you have in your state based
on your age, because if your goal is just to get
vaccinated, you may not need your mom's approval
depending on where you live. Number two, I don't
know how to convince your mom. I mean, this is
your anti vax. We've talked about a lot of non
science based beliefs. Anti vaccine is a really,
really stubborn one. It can be hard to clean that
one out, so to speak. And it could take months and
months and months. Again, if the goal is to get
vaccinated, you might be 18 before you convince
your mom and then in any state you'd be able to
go and get yourself vaccinated. So I feel for you.
I'm really glad to hear that. Even though
your mom is taking this view, you seem to
have figured out what makes sense when it comes
to vaccination and public safety. That's already a
great thing. You're already pointing in the right
direction as you enter adulthood, young adulthood.
But really it comes down to what are you willing
to do in order to get yourself vaccinated? The
answer is a very personal one. We will go into
more detail on the bonus show today about the
Delta variant, which is now predominant in the
UK and growing in the United States. We will talk
about a new California plan to pay off all past
due rent that accrued during the covid pandemic.
Very interesting decision by California and
Barack Obama. Former President Barack Obama
says if we can pass the voting rights bill with
the things Joe Manchin is OK with, it should be
done because it's better than nothing. At the same
time, if Mitch McConnell still won't go for it,
does it make a difference? The Senate is
debating today and we're going to talk more
about this on today's bonus show. Get instant
access. You just sign up and then you're in
to today's bonus show by becoming a member at Join
Pakman dot com. We'll see you then or tomorrow.